[Music]
for enemies is back and we're under fire
by all sides wait he didn't tell me this
everything was fine when i sat down you
didn't tell me right now the
enemies are under fire people are
criticizing our show
did you know that no okay first of all
you didn't tell me this i thought we
were having like a fun reaction well
we are but a few things came up and i
was like wow they're coming for us
inside first of all insider wrote an
article
oh they write an article like every day
though on me i feel like do they really
they're always like why do they
why do they pretend like they're like a
serious publication and then they go
well here it's called a podcast hosted
by two of youtube's most controversial
personalities first of all
you get that title you are pretty hated
and controversial
why hated more controversial because
your politics like i don't even watch
the h3 but it's like annoying and i
don't even watch it but i
hear about your politics just through
tick-tock through whatever and i'm just
like
okay yeah really and it's pretty
controversial you're pretty
segregated you're pretty much like who's
more controversial yeah who's between
you
no no you're like if you like trump you
suck and must die and i'm like oh my god
like that's the way literally didn't say
that
not literally but that's how you come
across okay hold on hold on hold on
that's not segregated people
like your president okay what if
let's not say let's not segregate
fascists out of our
audience that's what i'm saying you're
not okay i'm not trying to get political
on here obviously this is funny wait
what i wanted to ask you i wanted to ask
you what do you think about the news
of the mega riot at the capitol
don't tell me you didn't hear about it i
[Applause]
saw it on twitter uh-huh i don't know
anything about it
that's moses did you you guys didn't
watch anything about it then you guys
don't watch the news
been too busy yeah what a luxury it was
my appalachian week so
oh you were obviously yeah you guys were
busy huh
how busy can you be i mean wham bam
i mean damn dude um
i saw something on twitter and i asked
moses about it when it happened he's
like oh i don't know and then we just
like
let it go that's so nice i used to be i
mean i remember when i was like
really younger i felt that way about i'm
not saying that you're wrong i mean you
can feel whatever you want but
i just remember when i was a kid and my
parents would get all worked up about
politics and be like
whatever nobody cares and it's true you
know nothing ever changes but
trump is a fascist and uh not all of his
supporters are fascists but the ones
that stormed
the capital are fascist insurance why is
that happening you are very aggressive
about people supporting trump and you're
just like
you're an idiot
yeah yeah okay controversial because
like
in general i just try and be like
inclusive of everybody everything i try
i understand i try and people still want
to hold it against me i'm like you know
i'm just trying my best over here
okay so we're back to the headline we're
two of youtube's most controversial
person
personalities but i highly reject that
i'm more controversial
than you i don't think you're more
controversial i think
you're way more controversial than me i
think it used to be can i get it back
can i get a backup on that dan
like when i said dan i'm not
controversial he said what
so apparently i am controversial but
yeah i mean you're definitely
you're both controversial in very
different ways it's kind of apples and
oranges what do
i do who am i why do i get that label
all i am is just trying to be myself i'm
a better controversial than you
because i everything i'm controversial
for is on myself i say i'm transgender
d.i.d
you are like you you and me i'm like oh
me me me and everyone's like oh sure you
never talk [ __ ] about anybody in your
whole car who do i talk [ __ ] about
how about the entire internet james
charles the dixie family
uh gabby hannah
you were talking [ __ ] about the uh tyler
oakley
the last time you're talking about it
this one it brings it out on this
podcast because that's you
you're a talker so i'm a [ __ ] talker
with you but in my personal life i'm
like whatever
oh please
okay whatever i don't know what it is
about this podcast although i do feel
very confident to just should talk
people yeah
if it was it was just me i'd be more
scared but for some reason when i had
this microphone on this setting i'm like
well especially james charles this is
the anti-james charles podcast if we
need to say that again
i don't know in 2021 trish is kind of
like okay james we'll get okay wait
i gotta get back to this because there's
a whole okay
what i don't like 2021 trisha anymore
i love everybody i want to collab with
james charles yeah he's never going to
talk
you think maybe you will never never you
don't think he
despises you 2021 trish is new though
yeah he didn't buy that i don't buy 20
21 trisha either
i'm supportive of james charles now so i
don't why are you leaving me in the
trenches i thought we were going to war
with james charles i don't believe new
year knew everybody i feel james could
change
we could change really i'm a different
person now
what would i change about myself being
fat
i'm working on it yeah you're definitely
do i look skinnier than
i shaved so i think that always makes me
look fatter
well i also think you look skinnier
because your hair is grown out like you
know you're bald so it made you look
but also you dress like a toddler last
time you were dressed like a man so you
just look spelty now you look
you had a hat on earlier that was
horrible and i wanted you to wear it i
wasn't going to tell you i hope you did
you were going to wear it on the show so
he could be like oh my god why is he
dressed like a toddler
but now you kind of look like eminem so
you're kind of cool you're like why am i
a toddler i'm just wearing a t-shirt
the hat and the t-shirt you had together
yeah i agree the hat was bad and i took
it off
all right i like that you should try and
dress maybe we could do an episode where
we give each other makeovers maybe i
could buy clothes for you
and style your hair that's just i mean
okay but that's you
doing a makeover for me because you
could give me a makeover
what would i do you're already fresh no
but i'll take a makeover can i make you
over yes that'd be cool i like a cool
one like a real one
let's do it okay aren't you just gonna
turn me into like a drag queen
no that's what you want i think that's
your fantasy
no it's not my fan okay because you
really love being
the other gender here we go again one
guy except for uncle fester which you
did look just like
thank you jeffrey jeffrey and james
charles okay but they're
yeah but they're yeah shut up dan all
right let's move on
past this so anyway my only
communication with you this week was a
text like
did jeffrey really sleep with kanye i'm
like i don't know like when you text me
that i'm like how would i know that
why somebody was like somebody for some
reason was like trisha probably has some
intel on it
no it was so weird when you text i felt
like a like a fan texting me i'm like
who is this and i was like oh my god
why are you so sensitive just answer the
question i'm not sensitive i'm like but
that's the only communication i get from
you all week is
is the thing you want me to communicate
i don't know what you want from me you
want me to communicate you don't want me
to communicate
you text me too much you don't text me
enough what am i
i'm not your boyfriend or your fiance i
don't have to deal with this [ __ ]
you're my cause though you're the
co-host
text me you never text me uh
you never initiate conversations with me
that's true okay so
all right whatever whatever all right
can i read the headline please that's
where i'm supposed to look because
people always know that i'm looking at
myself where do you look where am i
supposed to look if not the monitors
well the camera's above the monitors you
look at the camera
sometimes okay it's hard not to look at
the monitor i agree
i look at myself but we know you're a
narcissist and you said you look bomb
today so you're going to want to look at
it i look bomb on this side i have
really bad acne on this side so let's
just keep profiling okay what is this
headline can i read the headline please
yeah papa um frenemies is under attack
that's gonna be the title it's gonna be
really good
friend of mine okay i like that that's
true though
most two of youtube's most controversial
personalities is creating new
conversations about mental health that
sounds good right
i don't like being a poster child for
like a mental health all of a sudden
it's like
bpd and mental it's just like i agree i
don't like it either we're just two
friends doing a podcast i
i did watch your h3 live a little bit
about someone saying like
i just hate that that's what it's about
like how dare he collab with a girl with
a mental health issues it's not like i
killed somebody and i should be like
locked in prison forever
also the insinua well the insinuation is
like that you don't have your own agency
that you're not your own adult making
your own choices it's like
ethan is exploiting trisha it's like
she well well no
trisha is an adult who makes her own
choices and we're just two friends
making a positive you're exploiting me
because i have like
something wrong in my brain so yeah if i
don't know that you're doing like that
what we're doing
like i know how i am on the internet
like my life right good point
it's your brand yeah and i'm like if i
have to deal with it i might as well
monetize off of it you know what i'm
saying
but also like i keep saying i love this
show like everyone just like stop the
podcast i'm like please don't stop this
podcast
let me read you what they said that's so
oh i hate that i'm like this person and
that our show is like
mental health awareness it's like why
it's just not that yeah i don't know
what nutcase
uh let's see eth klein who pokes and
antagonizes her appears ill
ill-equipped to deal with her
fluctuating mood swings again this is a
criticism i've gotten from several
people
i'm not a clinical therapist i'm not
equipped in any way to deal with
anything we're just two friends doing a
podcast this isn't
therapy i don't know what people want
i'm ill-equipped to deal with her
fluctuating mood swings like hello
who is it who i'm not i'm just a guy i
feel like i know i feel like i'm like
someone that needs a caregiver or
something because everyone's like
he's not equipped to deal with like i'm
not that bad i've had like
but also i don't handle it that bad
either it's not like i'm like
well [ __ ] you and we can't do that and
i'm flipping the desk they make it sound
so bad
you know i don't i think we're handling
it well i'm okay i mean i'm fine with it
actually because people actually are
tend to be more sympathetic towards me
is seeing an actual helper so i'm like
i agree and i and that's another reason
why i think it's good is because
that shit's real it humanizes you in a
way and it make me understand you in a
way i did it and i think that's good
and i got me a follow from dr drew on
twitter
watch out moses
oh here's another one viewers and mental
health professionals alike
mental health professionals who are are
unsure whether the podcast is good or
bad for mental health representation
on one hand it's incredibly rare to view
such raw conversations about mental
illness
on the other it could be considered
exploitative
i i just don't know why we became like
the
i just don't want to be that like i
don't want my identity to be
bpd like i follow a lot of tick talkers
that's all they talk about and that's
cool but it's also like
it's like being the fat girl like i want
to be the factor i don't know the crazy
girl i don't want to be the dude with
tourists either
yeah but i feel like you you're not
because people don't make like a big
deal of it well i don't
yeah and well it's like you could talk
about it and do the whole thing
which is fine i'm not criticizing but
the point is
they just want clicks they're just
they're being it's like how
what first of all and another point that
this guy uh d'angelo wallace who by the
way i like and i watch his videos and i
he's a fr and he's friend of the show
love d'angelo wallace the show
he's i think friends of h3 maybe yeah
not this show but he's not from these
on the black side of this desk this
friendship the pink side i can't talk
about
right yeah there's a line in the sand i
would say we
hate d'angelo wallace on the pink side
okay we like
we love him on the black side and we
hate him on the pink side i like that
there's a line in this i hate that
people consider someone like credible
just because they have like
a long video with like you know edit
cool editing it's like
this person's just like a random person
that highlights it's just like any
propaganda like i'm gonna show you all
the negative stuff okay wait you're
talking about the
like our launch video
live from him yeah oh well so i was
gonna pull let's let's
let's not stray too far from the path
but at any rate
he does make a point he he echoes a lot
of these points this
is like it's exploitative and so and
that
he also said that people are just
jealous that they that they
nobody cares about their shitty shows
and shitty content you know what i mean
like i hate people like this like anna
nicole
i remember her on a reality show some
girl comes up and goes you know they're
just like using you right and she's like
i don't care as long as i get paid
like yeah like this is our lives like
we're not supposed to have a career
would you imagine bpt and like target if
i was i was a target employee and guess
what i got fired
because i was paranoid i literally
thought that everyone was like literally
trying to kill me inside a target i
worked in the electronics department
marietta california when i was 18 years
old
and i thought everyone was trying to
murder me including my manager of the
electronics department and i got fired
so like
at least i'm given this platform where i
can make better money than working for
target
yeah so but wait so you i didn't know
paranoia was a symptom of
i think that's what i told you i think i
might be schizo i don't think so
um there was pair we looked up bpt the
other day there is paranoia yeah i don't
think you're skid so
but um i mean paranoid of everything for
sure i think moses is trying to
poison me in fact you know what i do
when we when i make food for him i take
a bite of mine he takes a bite of his
like you want to switch to make sure
that i didn't poison this food
and that's what we do now that's quite a
relationship
that's quite yeah i know which by the
way is a horrible movie we want he made
me watch it
i love that movie oh it's so bad he kept
talking about he's like you're gonna
love it
i know i'm not you know what's so weird
moses i do that
to ela and she reacts the same way
tricia does
i always go elo watch princess bride and
she goes i [ __ ] hate it oh really
isn't that so weird it's awful i don't
think it's a girl's movie i don't think
it is a girl's movie it's like a chick
flick no they try so hard to be funny
it's like not okay can we focus
conceivable guy i'm like please just
stop this movie right now i kept trying
to like postpone it anyways
yeah did you watch it more or less of
the amount that you watched schindler's
list
we made it through princess bride
although i was on my tick tock so
oh you watched it but you were on tick
tock yeah because i just didn't care
anymore the movie switched halfway
through i hate when
that happens okay but anyway d'angelo
said
a lot of the same things he said a lot
of nice things about both of us so i
don't want to make it seem like he
didn't
say nice things about us but what he
said
is um here let me pull it up we can
watch we're going to watch it
yeah it's a clip time stamp why are
people haters this is like a fun show
he's not he's ethan's podcast as well i
think he plays a huge part in this yes
like i said i truly believe that he does
his best to manage
trisha paytas and her outbursts it's
like once they happen he's
really happy to profit off of them
basically making
podcasts highlights out of her
breakdowns
the show in some way is kind of
dependent
on oh is trisha going to have a
breakdown this week so that
that point first of all i highly
disagree with because we've had two big
breakdowns on the show
yeah and i do not like when that happens
and by the way our episodes without
breakdowns do great
it's not like nobody watches when
there's no breaks yeah are you smarter
than a fifth grader one is just as much
as me storming out
and our steamies did really good yeah so
every episode we've done so so at that
point i i strongly disagree with you
know
now he he he made maybe his point about
being exploitative in terms of the
highlights
was kind of i was like okay i do do
highlights of that but
my my counter argument to that is that
um
if we're not going to put it up somebody
is oh he posted a response to us what
the f
this video goes deep oh i hate people
like this wait he put my dms to him in
the thumbnail what the f
oh those you really dm yeah i
i was like yo what do you put my i'm
what the
f i told him i'm gonna watch your shane
video tonight i'll report back i hate
that we've been talking about him though
because he's just so
like not important not entertaining and
she's just getting like
a few off of like like i hate talking
about drama channels because they're so
not original or funny or anything like i
like
deangelo his videos are very good that
being said
um i'd rather suck philip defranco's
left teeth than watch this video his
left
tit i thought you said tooth the hell
yeah that's like a
i just filmed a frank what was my point
is
that um we're under fire and people are
we're under fire and i feel like we
better address it now
because of what because i have a mental
illness you're my friend yeah exactly
that's what i think too thank you even
dr drew when he was here and i was like
yeah i don't deserve most i shouldn't be
in a relationship he goes no
like don't say that because like you're
worthy of a normal life just because you
have something wrong with you
oh my god like i didn't kill anybody my
goodness
yeah they like infant they make you like
uh what's the word infant
infantile or they they make it seem like
you you don't have any agency or choice
in your life
and that it's up to me to say no trisha
this isn't
acceptable because i'll be exploiting
you together yeah
you as like this god because you're just
as messed up as me i mean you got
tourette's
yeah i agree it's also is that a mental
illness it's not a mental illness what
is it a physical disability
uh it's a dis it's a syndrome i don't
know
so you got something wrong with your
brain so your brain
is not wired all the way right what yes
okay so my point
is it's like black leading the blind
like you're not
yes it's the blind leading the blind
damn why are you so much better than me
when you were also like
i think that well you're the one having
that outburst i guess is so they say
ethan's exploiting her
the show depends on her having outburst
it's all not true though that's all i
want to do
for another outburst if it happens but
not with you hopefully you know maybe
something else will provoke me
really like what we just go into what do
you want
yeah come on let's outburst
no i'm kidding you weren't even awake
and i was 15 minutes late today and then
dan's like oh ethan's not even up yet i
was like
is this out first are you going for that
person yeah i know no
that's true sometimes i watched it i
didn't watch h3 live a lot but when i
watched it this last week when you're
talking about me i
i i just really wanted to talk i had an
outburst that's why i texted you guys
during the show because i was like i had
a lot to say but then i had like i like
kept deleting it i was like
now let me just like not be so crazy on
the thing why were you criticizing me
i think i think i do in the moment
because i always think that you're on
the
i'm on the defense with you when you
were actually on my side and i'm always
on your side
always right right you don't believe it
that's fine i mean yeah but like but uh
anyway
so um that's what i just want to say is
that we are under attack
i gotta watch that video was it just the
insider and d'angelo
yeah it was just them right but that's
how but that's how it starts don't you
see those are two big sources
saying that they want to cancel our show
they want to cancel it
well there was a really nice and i'm
just saying that's how it begins then
all of a sudden it becomes this talking
point
and that this person's making a video
about a friend of mine is this
and that no there was a really nice one
i'm getting a call from a scam should i
answer it oh yeah
it's from a scam hold on i'm answering
it hello
hello
hi is this scam likely
um anyways that was great uh this
channel called psych in real life they
did help frenemies reveals a mental
health misconception
perpetuated by the internet this was a
really good one this was someone who was
like in our favor
some people are in our favor that we
show the ugly side of bpt they're like
you know what
everyone's a mental health advocate
until it's ugly and so
i kind of agree with that because
everyone thinks it's like cool and
trendy to be like mental health
awareness
but then as soon as someone has like an
outburst like why are you friends with
her why are you doing the show you're
manipulating you're exploring
like all this stuff like that it's like
like you know i agree
i'm like yeah also that same person did
the fall of h3h3
that [ __ ] up wait psych r
why is psyc irl making videos about the
fall of people
well they liked us well i'm still here
[ __ ] that video was two years ago and
i'm still here so [ __ ]
you psych rl no she was on our side for
a friend of me she was yeah well two
years ago
she was [ __ ] tap dancing on my grave
[ __ ]
you turned it around though um sorry i
didn't know she was a she's a female
yeah i should have said the b word you
said it right after the last night no
i'm sorry i did a whole thing but i
don't want to say it and then
yeah all right so you want to move on to
the okay that's it
i'm sure we could talk about it more
really i love this
job please stop trying to cancel us and
i love it too like stop like you know
like
that's the thing but here this time last
year everyone was criticizing me for not
having a mental disorder and now it's
like
oh church like is
the [ __ ] am i crazy am i not crazy like
what is it that's a really good
opportunity remember when everyone came
for me and now everyone's like wow like
don't be friends with her
why is she on the show you're exploiting
her it's like oh the [ __ ] that's really
interesting point
so back the [ __ ] off
let us just do our thing we're just two
friends do it as you know i mean what
the [ __ ]
i mean in d'angelo's defense a little
bit yeah
he he made it clear in that video that
he is a fan he's watched every episode
yeah he's watched every episode of the
show and he was very nice
and he said trisha he said you're
hilarious on this show
like he had he had positive things
that's the thing he said lots of good
things
and he was very kind but then said why
are you doing a show
with her he did say on the other hand
that ethan's even funnier than trisha on
the show
well then right away just kind of he
said that so he is not incredible i kind
of left that part out
yeah i can't wait to watch his video i
should wait till um i think you're
funnier but i definitely am more
entertaining
i think you are so fun sometimes i watch
the episodes back
and and i don't catch exactly the stuff
you're saying
in the moment and i'm like because you
don't listen to me i listen to
everything you're saying but it's like a
fast-paced conversation i don't have
time to process everything
um thank you but you're you're very very
funny and sometimes i'm like wow
round of applause for chris very funny
wow
thank you thank you are you more
entertaining
yeah yeah you're like uh the whole
triple threat yeah i think if we like
had a reality show like who would get
the reality oh yeah
you there's nothing good about my
reality
there's nothing well no it's good it's
just not it's just boring but it's good
it's peaceful it's loving
we get for a show it's nothing to watch
right you would make a great reality
show um
i would never do it unless the real
housewives of beverly hills
let me know yeah but mo i don't think
moses is posh enough to be uh
because you have to be like no that's so
not even true they're not even that posh
on that show like
vicky gunwilson the girl from orange
county she literally has like no money
they rent a condo no offense anyone who
runs a condo but like why is she on the
show
that's the thing a lot of them are fake
bougie this other guy named slade was on
it had no money like it's
you know they're fake boujee but it's
fine they can't find real bougie people
in all of la to be on that show i mean
they have like lisa rinna
you would [ __ ] you would destroy that
show you put all those girls in their
place
and no they're like old women no offense
yeah break them
i'd be young on that show i'd be 32.
i'll be the young one okay you said
you're leaving tick tock and apologizing
and then you were back
what happened okay guys let me watch for
real i'm leaving social media
it's a really toxic place and i wish you
all well
and um i want to apologize to
charlie dixon why did you make this
video and why did you film it like
you're in a
tent fort i was naked and moses was also
next to me and i didn't want him in the
tik tok so i was like let me just cover
my whole body and to show my eyes
just forehead um i wanted to apologize
to charlie
because it's 2021 yeah but you're still
on social media you like
didn't you well that was like a troll
trish but that was like a
not harm like when people like take that
seriously because i did like four saying
i'm quitting i'm like how are they still
taking that seriously
okay okay fair enough and then what was
this one really caught my attention on
instagram you posted
a picture of groceries uh
you posted a picture of skippy extra
crunchy
single craft single american yeah la
croix
pure sparkling water yeah uh
bread just the bottom part where it says
visit
the capri sun fruit punch uh
tater tots tater tots butter well that
was
more for you why
because i wanted to like make grilled
cheese this episode i thought that'd be
fun but
you posted this as a weird subliminal
way of communicating with me yeah
i thought maybe you won't see it because
you dm me and said oh you don't follow
me and i said why do you
why do you communicate so cryptically
because i thought you would pick it up
like you pick up stuff like that
how is this girl how does this even meet
grilled cheap hold on hold on hold up
why is there peanut butter with the
grilled cheese you put peanut butter on
one side
butter on the other and then the cheese
in the middle if you want me to think
peanut butter
if you want me to think grilled cheese
why would you start with peanut butter
that's like a horrible tension though
didn't it you scrolled through
yeah i was like what i thought you did
this by mistake or something
no i thought maybe you might get the
ingredients because we didn't have we
have the ingredients wow
this is this is the biggest [ __ ] post
ever on in instagram history
why because you're like you're just
posting pictures of groceries and the
hope that i see it i understand you want
to make real cheese i thought you might
because you dm me prior saying oh i'm
following you now like you don't follow
me and i was like okay i'll follow you
i responded girl what i was so excited
wasn't i excited when he did that too
because i was like this was for ethan
and he responded
so i thought you got it okay but this is
not good
you lead with peanut butter that that
doesn't make any sense trisha
okay we have peanut butter and craft
okay so craft is and then you go lacroix
which just does nothing to do why would
you do lacroix because the pure one goes
with the grilled cheese it pairs nicely
i can't even see that it's pear it just
shows the top pure
no it pairs nicely with a grilled cheese
pure
pears like you know it says pure this
isn't pear this one is in pear flavor oh
my god
it's not it's i know but
and it's pure the pure as well it's just
soda water
exactly you don't want lemon with
grilled cheese
you really think i'm psychic white vandy
camp
i loved our mukbang why caprice oh my
god and then why the tater tots
it goes with grilled cheese dude you
really that's incredible i thought maybe
you would like get the hint and we would
do it oh can we redo are you smarter
than a fifth grader what can we do like
pop culture trivia
sure because i feel like i need to like
i feel ever since that episode i feel
really bad that i lost like i've never
lose
i never lose i never really did it i
think everyone was really impressed
it wasn't fair though because the
anyways we can keep going but i
rewatched that episode and i was like oh
my god
like they need to redo it because i'd
love to redo that they each bring in
like
4 000 cash oh put it on the table
but no we start with like two thousand
then we could do double or nothing
whoever like wins like a double or
nothing and then you go four thousand
dollars cash will be the winner
i think you just got to put it on the
table and the winner takes off no you
should do like best three
like win and then if like the winner can
say like double or nothing
that's more exciting because the loser
can redeem himself anyways
i love trivia i'm so good at trivia
games not as good as me
that is not i'm trying to find where uh
oh i know you went to college here it is
oh did you see now back what else are we
talking about
okay so we're gonna watch all your tv
appearances
okay i love this yeah i thought you
would like it i hope you will like this
episode this one feels kind of bad
well there's not as much prep i mean the
stream the steamies happen
here we're just kind of trying to do an
episode i mean what do you want to talk
about something else no i love watching
my
enemies is under attack what do you
understand about that we didn't go very
hard for anybody we're just like okay
i shredder all right you were on ellen
what do you do
i read okay did anya did anything cringy
actually i hate
like anyone can tell you like i hate
watching myself on tv especially this
era of trash i'm so
cringy did any ellen producer try to
grope you or anything
no no they were all gay oh they were
ellen is a [ __ ] really yeah i could
tell
she's but when all that stuff started
coming out i was like that makes sense
because she was
so awful like literally would not talk
they tell her don't look in her eye
and then they told you that yeah they're
like don't look in her eyes don't touch
her so in this clip i say
oh i'm not supposed to touch you because
i go like this and i'm like oh i'm not
supposed to touch you like you hear me
saying it because before they're like
don't oh and they think you're a weirdo
but they're the weirdos yeah they're
like if you touch her you'll be escorted
off like mid show we don't care i was
like
okay and then i touched your ass what a
diva you're just ellen you're just a
tv host you're not the [ __ ] queen i
know i was so nervous wait
i didn't okay this see this is great i'm
glad we're doing this
you know like yeah oh you read that's
your favorite so people hug her and
stuff and they go up there
maybe like audience members okay we were
pre-picked
okay all right
you're
[Applause]
you're like looking in a mirror did you
rehearse that line
um no you know whenever i go on these
shows especially when it's younger this
is what i'm talking about the blackout i
don't remember anything like when people
ask me how
like i don't remember saying any of this
that's why it's crazy to watch like even
like america's hotel like all that stuff
is so crazy you're so
young i thought i thought you're doing
really well though it's like 22. it's
funny
well they found me on youtube so like
this they act like they picked you from
the audience but
you're you're not they just contact you
from youtube
did you touch her or it didn't happen
yet it's right here see i'm touching her
right now
all right you said i shouldn't touch it
yeah
yeah i need a book or something okay i i
have a
i have eel this is so crazy okay you can
read my book
all right should i should i hold this
for you um
oh you're mike okay great all right okay
on a spider has to be the scariest thing
in the world actually you know would be
scarier if after putting on the one
character to put me on the other one
discovered that i was teaming with
hundreds of spiders all the babies were
in there hole let's see it's a
cousin school of fish what does group of
slightest clothes remember whole stores
that would be scarce
oh came down
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the background this is so weird but you
are your time you're such a comedian
with your timing and everything
you think yeah you go this is the scary
part and then okay
um it's super cringe i don't know like
this was back in like this was before
like instagram this was like 2009 so
maybe when instagram first started
and like i just wanted to be famous you
know now it's so easy with like
tick-tock and all this stuff to go viral
but like i just wanted to be like
my thought was if i go on all these
shows someone will discover me like i
thought ellen was gonna discover me and
i was going to be like a co-host of hers
you know what i mean
like that was my yeah she's like don't
look at her don't touch her
we're going to be coho someday well
that's your theory like even america's
got talent i thought oh like howard's
going to love me he's going to ask me to
be on the show
i mean it's pretty epic that you were on
all these yeah i tried you know
so how did you get on the show youtube
they just found i had a oh they reached
out
oh the show is it america's got talent
reach out to me like guinness like they
all worked out
it's a guinness egg as a world record
it's not possible
than that whoa and they slow it down too
so you could like hear that i said i've
messed up once
oh names and pseudonyms 45 seconds
what is this this is trivia david
arquette wait isn't this this looks
recent
no it was like four years ago uh bruce
lee
um oh she has a talk show host big black
lady you're just a contestant
no you're just a contestant yeah me my
mom so it was like a celebrity name game
so i was like you had to go on with a
partner and so me and my mom you're the
celebrity
no david arkansas well why are you there
so you get paired with a celebrity and
it's all pop culture which we
killed this we won we beat the other
team um i'm really good so like pop
culture and craig ferguson was the host
it was a fun show
dude david arquette i gotta tell i think
you're dave
david arquette maybe back then he was
more relevant
you're more famous than david arquette
he should be he should be on your page
okay you should have said that was never
that nice to me i've met him
a couple times and he never really never
liked me it seems like there's a common
thread that all these people are not
nice to you are they really not nice to
you david or kenmore have no because
some people are really nice quentin
tino's nice eminem is really nice like
there's people who are like overtly nice
um david arquette seemed annoyed with me
every time i met him like a few times
yeah [ __ ] him calling him out right now
we can have well no david arquette if
you're watching and listening
we're calling you out courtney cox is
very cold she's definitely one like
don't touch me
but because she's also playing with us
oh she is yeah oh
um he was in the dragon the yellow suit
did you win money or something yeah how
much do you get 8 000.
yeah no not a princess but uh queen
let's take it out okay
um oh um she was a blonde bombshell in
the 50s she's uh
wow you're really good at this thanks he
sings the grenade song
the little one the little grenade song
oh i thought he is little
he's funny
[Music]
it's like david vlogs
[Applause]
really he's being nice come on no he
said he's fun to watch you play
because you're so energetic i don't i
don't think he wanted to [ __ ]
no i don't think so i don't think that's
what he meant and i thought in that show
too i thought oh craig ferguson will
probably have me on as a guest
my dream in life was to always be like a
talk show guest you know i used to like
pretend did you ever do that i feel like
a lot of people did
what are you talking about yeah like
where you're interviewed by like uh
like jay lana oh like you sit in you're
the interviewer you're like oh thanks so
much for having me this is really great
i actually don't
actually you never fantasized that no
and and i really
never want to go on a show like that
because it's just so nerve-wracking i
hate it
really yeah i don't like it because
you're sitting there and you have to be
funny and then everybody's watching you
and everyone's you know what i mean and
it's like short yeah
i think i would have liked it in like
the 90s when like you could be like
sexually harassed by david letterman
like i loved those he's like come here
girl
yeah yeah yeah it's crazy you can't do
that right here come here girl slap your
titties no they totally did remember
johnny carson did that with dolly parton
he like squeezed her tits
really yeah he's like can i feel him
here can i punch you in the tits
or pamela anderson too she got sexually
harassed a lot by like jay leno and
david letterman they were always saying
like about her like sucking dickens i
was like oh that's pretty cool yeah
hey the [ __ ] deport the pork boys did
that to you on the bff's podcast
it's pork boys the pork pork boy david
portney
david portney if you if you want me back
i'll come on your show again
i liked him i thought he wasn't cool
what they were so rude too
i don't know i didn't get i didn't get
that vibe i guess it's the same way
people think you're exploitative i think
from the outside maybe people see it
differently
i don't know he he is exploitive he's
rude and he's the enemy of the show
no that's d'angelo no you have a condom
on your head
yeah jello is a friend of the show no
he's not
here let's watch
[Applause]
oh this is really cringe this is like i
can't watch this with anybody
my name is trisha paytas i am 23 years
old yeah i've never tried out before
because i never liked
the judges but that's my boyfriend
that's your boyfriend i just want to
look at his beauty he's just so
beautiful
now do you love these do you really love
these people are you just because i feel
like you don't really like
ellen oh ellen i never said i was a fan
of ellen well you okay because you acted
like you're like oh you can't believe
here i love you you're so beautiful
howard i'm a huge fan of like because
that's why i am the way i am like he had
a show on e where like girls were naked
at like midnight
and i was like i want to be that girl
because he thought they were so like he
wanted to [ __ ] all these girls like i
wanna you know so like to me
he was like the epitome like i was like
oh i want to meet howard stern he's
another one i thought maybe would leave
his wife for me
oh my goodness trisha i love your
i love your uh your ambition i was
but i'm like dead serious when i say
that like i literally thought oh he
looks at me like he probably will leave
beth from oh my goodness but then the
next day he literally came from me and
said she looks like pamela anderson if
she would lose 40 pounds i was like
that's brutal especially by someone you
love but he was
but i think i think he's definitely
shaking kind of a compliment though
yeah because he thought pamela anderson
was like the sexiest girl like for in
the 90s he like loved pamela
um but i think it's a stick because like
you know when i met him like because
after the show i got to like talk to him
more and he was like
so nice like so like unbelievably nice
like i was like wow why are you so nice
to me and like
nicer than howie was a kind of a prick
sharon was okay but
howard was really nice nick cannon a
prick too but howard was like overtly
nice to me for no reason
he probably wanted to leave his wife for
you [ __ ] you think i missed my
opportunity maybe i should have lost 40
pounds before i went on the show
damn it you could be mrs stern right now
i was going to go on a show and like
have him weigh me like he didn't have a
nipple
this was so scary this was austin
wow hi
they're shouting vegas they just want me
to go through based on my looks you look
like you
oh my god that's so ridiculous that was
great okay
you never know they reached out to you
they reached out to me
many seasons so and then the fast
talking was your skill like what's your
skill
america's got talent sabotages and i saw
a girl and tick tock go viral she's an
actual talented person she
she was like they wanted her to like
sing a pink song and look like pink and
she goes oh i kind of don't want to
because like you know i just want to
show my talent
anyways like no you have to sing a pink
song so she sings a pink song and then
all the judges like you're trying too
hard to be pinky original
and the girl went viral because she's
like that's she was like
she was traumatized after that because
she's like an actually good singer so
dirty and honestly they did that with me
i was so mad so
this is after um i did a couple fast
talking things but this was after all
that
and they were like we want you on here
to be like a fast talker so they told me
that i was going to do star spangled
banner like you're going to like talk as
fast as you can
so had to have that whatever like no no
we're going to change it we have a beat
for you go out there and freestyle as
fast as you can oh
it's so dirty and they told me minutes i
waited six hours and in austin texas
they flew me yeah i wouldn't
uh that's so [ __ ] up they are creating
all these crazy situations
they oh that's so dirty like literally
literally a minute before it they're
like okay
change of plans we don't have star
spangled banner approved so you're gonna
go out there and
freestyle freestyle they would go as
fast just talk as fast as you can over
this beat
i was like what like
you know how [ __ ] up that is because
yeah i know no yeah okay the star
spangled
banner people got back to us last minute
they gave us a no on that
yo because they they that's actually so
exploitative because
you showed up you spent all this time so
if you're like no i'm not going to do
that then they're like okay go home
and i was in austin texas they flew me
to austin oh brother because they didn't
want me to be another then if you go on
stage
that they [ __ ] you that's so messed up
they're humiliating these people that i
don't like that
no they did it after my interview with
nick cannon so the interview with nick
and he's like you're gonna go out there
and be a fast talker i'm like yeah
and then like they're saying it like as
they're introducing you for the next
person
and they're like they're like oh no like
they've already seen you they already
love you like they tell you they hype
you up as if you're gonna be good
in my head i already kind of knew i was
like obviously not gonna win because
that talent was fast talking i just
thought it was a good way
again to see howard stern because they
offered me this when piers morgan was
the host and i said no because i was
like i don't want to be humiliated this
early on in my career now i would be
like whatever [ __ ] humiliate me
but back then i still thought i could be
taken seriously by like quentin
tarantino maybe he put me in a movie
now i was like oh [ __ ] that but i went
on because howard was the judge
this was the first year he was a judge
and i was like you know what i'll do it
this year because i really truly my
heart thought howard stern would be like
my best friend
were you looking at him and trying to be
like like put it on
put on the moves to him a little bit
like i didn't until i got humiliated and
then
in my like my fight or flight was like
okay trish make this really entertaining
make this quirky here's your chance talk
to howard
and then it turned around and it was
totally good in my favor but you did
have a good experience with howard
actually he was great and he came on
stage and danced with me and it was
you work in vegas really i know i get
that a lot someone thought i was a
stripper or a poor star i'm like nope i
love jesus i'm not like that
you're really funny that was a good one
what's your name i think my name is
trish like fish
trish and she's my tick-tock she's like
fishing
trish i'm fascinated but that's like not
funny like people laughing
it's goofy but like i think what's
happening here is that you're actually
being really funny and people
the way that you put it out you put it
like oh i'm just ditzy and i'm and i'm
just a dumb girl but like you're
actually being funny
and it gets lost but like that's that's
a great line i think early on like i
definitely was like that high-pitched
voice i wanted to be like jessica
simpson i was like okay i'm gonna be
dumb but like
i think like now smartness pays off i
mean i think i'm like dumb in some way
it's like whatever but now i think
people appreciate that you're actually a
funny person now which is good
thank you oh my god somebody compliments
this episode it's true you're hilarious
can that be the title trisha is funny
no absolutely not who's gonna click that
[Music]
i'm like a computer programmer but i
work at my house so no one ever sees me
i was a stripper and they told me to
make up another job and at the time oh
you are a stripper yeah
that's not true i love jesus see that's
well i did love jesus why did you say
you're a computer programmer they asked
me to come up with another job and my
brother was a computer programmer
i think i was a waitress online but
you're selling it so good you're like i
sit at home and i'll be sleeping i'm a
pro programmer
what are you gonna do today i do youtube
um i talk really fast
and like i'm a rapper yes a rapper oh my
god you're not
i can't believe they made you go out to
your rapper they told
me last minute they're like they love
that you rap because oh because at the
time i did some videos where i thought
maybe they saw it i was like wrapping to
nicki minaj on the internet and like
twist on all these things and i was like
oh maybe they saw it
this is so embarrassing a rapper
so cringe this is so funny every single
summer when i turn them on tv i'm
watching each week and how should we be
on the stage
what are you reading i'm not this is off
the top of my head no way
yeah because when they told me this i
started thinking of all the things i
could rhyme
so i was like you turn on your tv you're
watching egt like i'm just like trying
to think no way
seriously yeah i mean it's not good
you're fast no but you're rhyming really
fast
oh wow right away
dude they [ __ ] you so hard and look at
hey
sounds like oh [ __ ] but it's not your
fault they screwed you
[Applause]
i'm like what do i do
it was just annoying for me it was very
annoying it was it gave me a headache
and i'm i'm not feeling well let's go to
shower
trisha it's so messed up that they like
they bring people out and they humiliate
them yeah they definitely do that even
with talented so messed up
i'm not okay there's twins on youtube
named nikki and gabby and
they also had they were on xbox and they
had a very similar experience where they
they changed the song last minute on
them and then they played the wrong
track on purpose
and they're good singers too but it's
not okay to bring people out and
humiliate them like like this is
unethical
that's exploitative and that reality tv
kills
for sure for sure i couldn't understand
anything you were saying
yeah because it was that quick rapper i
just need to make up a talent to see how
it's turning
oh well that's different see
so now the audience like whoa
this was so odd like the turn of events
on an all-new
they didn't show it okay so it was such
an odd turn of events because all of a
sudden now everyone's like cheering and
then he comes up on stage and dances
with me and like they're trying to judge
me and it's like awesome the crowd's
like cheering i'm like what this is
do i stay dead no you can leave now i
said that i said oh like am i going to
go to vegas because he's like we're
going to have a very nice day in the
mental institution
fast forward to 10 years later i'm in a
mental institution right you called it
howard
thanks howard when she slammed girls who
dressed sexy
it sparked out you told me to kill
myself and
controversy wait you're on the trigger
you just say she's a loose woman she's
wearing the uniform move on
you were trouble girl and dr phil no no
i wasn't
dr phil's on my side this guy hated me
for dressing sexy which i'm like what it
was so weird and dr
phil how did you end up on dr phil they
called me and said there's a hater that
wants to confront you and dr phil and
i'm like all right
god these shows are so outrageous this
is someone
so who's this guy he didn't he thought i
dressed like a [ __ ]
and he just is a follower and you i kind
of come confront this weirdo
yeah i was like all right oh my god
okay trying to
out do each other's sexuality define who
you are
you're gonna decide what somebody should
quit is this [ __ ] good censorship
fun fact about dr joe or dr drew dr phil
i'm sorry my mind is always on dr drew
um uh dr phil they they put me in a
turtleneck when i got there
and then because they told me to bring
all conservative clothes which i don't
know why the whole point was me dressing
sexy and then as soon as i got like
literally seconds before
they're like if she's not showing
cleavage she can't go out so they had to
like get like a like a
low cut top for me and stuff like that
they're like because i guess they wanted
me to dress sexy but then there was
miscommunication
but i guess dr phil said wear a
turtleneck someone said wear a
turtleneck and then dr phil's like
she needs to wear show cleavage and so
they're like get a [ __ ] shorter shirt
oh my god
what if you just wanted to stare at my
cleavage maybe i can't dr phil is a
creep
sorry he was also very cold he was like
looking at a quick get her
what what what'd you say he kind of was
like looking at a corpse
he the way he was made up looks like a
dead body he's like
but in person you know when you see
makeup in person it's like so much worse
and you're just like
are you real dr phil get this girl
look on top where she's not going out on
tv
some crazy perverted outbursts
yum okay so this is very good
i'm outside so you're you're yes we
should come out and get
exercise in the club
not as interesting being a trooper on
everything yeah
were you really addicted to tanning
i don't remember you don't even remember
i think
look i was always really tan i was
always very tan i liked tanning
i don't know if it was like necessarily
a problem where like i couldn't stop
but i definitely went to like five
tanning beds a day and like spray tan
and all that holy [ __ ]
so wait how did you get hooked up with
my strange addiction
craigslist they found you on craigslist
i found them
they didn't say the name of the show
because it didn't exist this was the
pilot episode when it was on discovery
house what was the description
they're like oh are you addicted to
something like yeah
oh my god they're like the more bizarre
did they pay you 500
wow my family always refuses to be on
anything with me so my mom's like the og
who will like be on tv with me like my
sister refuses my brother refuses shut
up i love supportive moms
she'll be on anything board of moms are
everything she'll like go with anything
i think i made up oh this addiction so
my mom was like they told her to be like
concerned so my mom's like i'm really
concerned
meanwhile these shows are so fake i know
your mom is just as funny as you are
she's like i'm so concerned that's
awesome
wow reality shows so they're all fake
all of them
i just use my hand that's no funny
what is this looks like the beginning of
a porn like what the [ __ ] is the show
it was super sketchy it was like one
producer and one camera person they came
to like our apartment to film
i thought it was super famous though i
was like oh my god like i have a
reaction i wonder if they had even
sold it yet you know what i mean if it
was just a couple dudes with a camera
yeah i don't think so
oh bro because it was a pilot so i think
you're pretty bold to show up to that
that could have gone wrong for you
craigslist yeah but you know what i
always i always say this if something
goes wrong like if they murder me i'll
be infamous you know
at that time you thought even maybe like
a craigslist killer situation like they
got me on craigslist
and you know they murdered me and so you
really justify it in your mind like
well that'll be cool to be killed by a
serial killer yeah
wow that's pretty [ __ ] up
but interesting yeah i gotta hand it to
you you
have a way of uh comforting yourself
yeah i think it's great you know i
watched seoul this past weekend on
disney and
they were talking about the afterlife
and the great beyond and i was like
honestly you can just fly back to earth
once you're dead
i don't think so i didn't watch that
show you believe in the afterlife
yeah what do you think the afterlife is
like fully conscious you just zip around
like a ghost
ah you have to watch the movie i think
we are soul nailed it
okay they really did soul nailed that
that's what you make it
i think the afterlife is what you use so
if i watched seoul
the new pixar film for kids then i will
understand the afterlife
yeah okay good they also talk about
before you come into life like the
the young souls i gotta check that out
it's really good i heard it got mixed
reviews
who said it was bad disney oh it was
disney pixar
yeah it is it is yeah they bought pixar
all right go disney they should be dan
because
we do a lot of stuff together and we're
always in pictures together and they
just look
bad did you put stuff on your face no
you just heard that stuff on your hand
and when i take my makeup off
it will look stupid like when my mom
tells me stuff about my face and
asian wrinkles i'm not concerned about
it why worry about something now that's
not going to happen for
a long long time i know but when you
have bronzer that takes the place of the
sun so they're like okay no
no just be concerned yeah literally they
kept telling her be like aren't you
concerned not putting lotion on her face
this was so awkward
our producer was horrible on this show
they were really bad wait is that
you or your mom oh me i just think it's
because
i'm sorry no no no it's just the tan
is so incredible i was very yeah i was
he pointed to the double you china drink
i don't do drugs but i think everyone
kind of has those
little indulgences that they you know
have and i think tanning is just mine so
if the one unhealthy thing that i do is
going to kill me then oh well
because you guys don't have to think
about your skin at a young age what if i
die tomorrow it won't matter then will
it i know
you said you'll be happy because you're
dude your mom is hella tan she's very
dangerous
again well i'm sure i won't die from
cancer people die every day from cancer
and people die from skin cancer
yeah i'm not laughing at that i'm just
like oh this is great i just feel like
sometimes
i gotta get away with it
you did yeah where and then my lower
back they like
i think i think the scar is gone from my
liposuction now when they did it but
they took out a little bit of skin
cancer in my lower back so i do spray
tan now i don't go in the thing but
you're not tanned like that i mean you
look normal now well now but sometimes
my spray tan i get a little dark like my
princess jasmine cosplay but
um oh spray tin yeah that doesn't come
yeah so so
you did have a little skin cancer yeah
that is a fun fact thanks for
manifesting that tlc
right that would never have happened
without that show
who is this guy i believe it jason
horton welcomes more challenges
paytas poor jason horton he was so
poppin and my youtube channel is
youtube.comdoll
for mj and on that channel i mean beauty
videos i make comedy videos
i make political videos political oh
yeah
i told you about that what i was on like
larry king and the young turks and stuff
i used to be political
you just made fun of me for being a
controversial youtuber what was your
take were you liberal
no that's conservative i was pushing
hard for mitt romney really mitt romney
i think it's probably still up why i
voted for mitt romney
i like mitt romney now yeah i was called
like the aura or something or some show
on youtube he was hosting you were a
conservative pundit
yeah and i i would give my commentary on
the debates i'm sure it's still up
somewhere
fun fact i never voted before this
election oh my god
that is also a fun fact so wait even the
political shows are fake you got this
girl pretending to care about politics
who's never voted in her life
it was so odd and they were asking me
about the dates and i never watched the
debates and i was like
yeah wow i think mitt romney is going to
send it home for us
oh my god yeah you know he wears magic
underwear
what's that he's mormon they wear magic
underwear oh yeah i know all about
mormon underwear
have you ever had sex with a mormon the
peel their magic underwear off no
actually that's crazy i've had sex with
a muslim a jew
christian but no mormons i guess they
have standards because it's hard to like
have sex with them you have to find a
really deviant one you have to like
marry them
yeah even donnie osmond every time i
take a picture with him his hand hovers
like this
yeah oh really dude the mormons are wild
yeah they wear magic underwear which is
kind of dope you know just why not
i wouldn't try it for a tick tock should
we get it for the next episode can you
find some magic or is that
i feel like that's probably
disrespectful you think
yes can we get married with a hopa
or do i have to be joking no you i i
think you can
oh okay i think you can get a hoop bug
going but
don't if but also maybe wear magic
underwear on your wedding night
but we're not more men yeah but just you
know who cares mormons let us know if we
can wear magic underwear because i would
just like to try it it's not
disrespectful
i don't think it's i don't think it's
called magic underwear by the way either
i think it's like mormon underwear or
something i've heard about it
the shows don't i don't like this show
yeah why are they showing this when i've
been on like modern family tim and eric
like i've been on like legit stuff
this list isn't good oh big brother
though it was kind of iconic
i'm trisha paytas and i am an internet
sensation
what my videos are my life oh my god
yeah
i talk about sex i talk about love how
to lick your own vagina
how to lick your own vagina did you say
that yeah that was an adam and eve
sponsor
how do you lick your own vagina well
they had a tongue vibrator back then so
i was like oh it's just a gag
yeah okay i can't lick it actually
myself
i was like something doesn't add up here
there is definitely no subject
off-limits to me
it's very dangerous to know me or even
talk to me because you will be talked
about on my channel
cringe that's true i can describe myself
in three words
i love the intro video so what did they
miss there's some they missed
um i did the tim and eric show i did
modern family
i did the longest yard with adam sandler
those are movies i guess these are our
game shows they just showed my reality
show stuff i
oh who wants to be a superhero with stan
lee i was on like seven episodes of that
on sci-fi network when i was 18 years
old like why are you
doing that you were like a mink yeah i
was a superhero one of stanley
superheroes and then i was on
the greg baron show when i was 18 years
old co-hosting oh that's why i got
kicked off because i did not know my
power but i do know my powers now my
name was miss limelight my powers were
didn't know your power you didn't
prepare for the role i got i got evicted
for that reason stanley's like
you're a superhero but you don't know
your powers sorry the
light is dimmed on you excelsior and
then he like got rid of me wait that was
your character
so you all had to be superheroes on the
show and you were competing to get a
comic book written by stan lee
and i don't know anything about it it
was a reality show yeah oh what the hell
it was called who wants to be a
superhero and so we had to compete we
went to six flags and would like do all
these challenges and like these be
anyways i was on for like four episodes
and then or five maybe and then i got
kicked off for not knowing my
superpowers and i don't really know my
superpower is i'm sure it's online my
name is miss limelight who wants to be a
superhero look at my super mrs limelight
they made it up for me i had no interest
in superheroes or anything i don't know
why i'm here and all these people were
nerds on the show like you they were all
like
oh she's spiderman i was like yeah
anyways
um i've been on like legit stuff so
so what is there anything else left to
talk about this was kind of just a
little
this was just a fun little app you know
it's not that serious ethan slept in so
he had nothing planned
one is not related to the other and by
the way what did you plan what do you
plan
i can plan something i'm always telling
you to plant something mormon underwear
next week i'll bring it
and we can't wear mormon underwear okay
next episode mormon underwear grilled
cheese mukbang and
trivia pop culture edition okay are you
gonna do
you oh you like that yeah so we're gonna
put on mormon underwear
us back we can do that because i have a
feeling that it's okay if we're if we're
appreciating and not appropriating
but the thing is the the mormons it's
like
what are they gonna do they're so like
pacifists you know what i mean
um i got offered so there was this
company i was going to work for
like a sponsorship like my tic tocs and
my youtube channel and i love the
company i like wear their clothes and
stuff for real
like i actually buy like you can attest
to it like i actually buy like thousands
of dollars worth of clothes from them
like a month like because they're cheap
and they're great
and um they're like they had a phone
call with them and they're really low
ball at first but then they came back
and they're like
um what do you think if we can like do a
promotion on like frontiers i'm like oh
i can put you in touch with ethan like
he deals with it or whatever they're
like oh what if you just like
mention our name and not really do a
plug so they wanted me to just mention
the name organically oh what's slime
bags
and i was like well i don't know i feel
kind of weird like if i'm just like
plugging it like if i'm like hey this is
from whatever
and um but they were trying to like
wheel that into the deal
like they were basically like okay we
can give you a little bit more money but
also can we get a shout out in front of
me but they didn't want to go through
you or like get a traditional oh what's
this
mentioned and i told him i talked to
moses like should i do it like it's just
like i'll have to say as their name once
and then they're like okay
that's pretty slimy thanks for telling
me yeah because i probably would have
noticed
no because i mentioned them once on the
show and they said that they're like
were you and i wasn't for a sponsorship
i literally said did they did you end up
closing the deal
no no i didn't i was going to say you
can say the name
this is my deal this is the deal they
owe you for this it's okay what's the
name
what if i actually did the deal with
them and i'm like this high working into
the show
oh pay up you [ __ ]
oh no they're not hustle they're not no
that's that's super
sketchy just
honestly if you told me and you're like
they just want me to mention i would be
fine with it but i appreciate you
telling me
thanks i just had like you know next
week i'm going to promote my music video
and my own clothing so i was just like
you know let me just like not get all
these sponsors right here
i'll just save it for myself at the top
of the show next week
of your show of our show are you going
to plug them next show no no i have a
music video coming out next week that i
want to plug and i was like let me just
save the plug for something
save the plug i have a teddy fresh plug
coming up
i guess that's one maybe okay we'll do a
mutual plug okay we'll just do like a
plug episode we should do an episode
that's just plugs yeah
honestly like they were really like a
low ball too and i was like i could
say it was like 40 000
but it was like it's a lot 10 tick tocks
10 youtube videos 10 instagram
that's insane that's crazy and you have
to whisper our name into the mic during
friend meets when ethan's not listening
no they said that they're like what if
we can just naturally put it in there
oh that's a horrible deal and i like
because i did mention it once before i
was like oh me
they're like you have to do everything
for us forever and we'll give you forty
thousand dollars
oh i can't imagine the kardashians do
that they probably
don't know the kardashians don't fart
unless they get paid a million
bucks yeah maybe next time i don't like
them
is it fashion nova it was fashionable
[ __ ] scumbags did you talk to them
before
no but i just see it no [ __ ] fashion
nova
they make cheap garbage they cater to
plus size cheap garbage i love it
all from we give them the fun yeah i
swear i didn't get any money
no i only said fashion nova because i
see them all over instagram and people
are like
fashion nova i love fashion nova i was
like what is with this fashion nova
[ __ ] you know what i like is it is
really cheap and it does go for plus
size and they don't make you wear it
i am against fast fashion it's very bad
for the world
and usually they steal their designs too
from other people
um well i mean that's not my problem
i don't want to nope not your problem
i'm not trying to [ __ ] up your deal i'm
just saying
fresh has been accused of stealing some
designs from really
i don't think so early on it was very
gucci-esque oh well
esque is not stealing well by the way if
somebody's gonna say you're a gucci
ass that's a compliment hmm the designs
look very similar early on i loved how
fresh it's become its own thing now i
love it
really the early the beginning ones were
super unique and weird
no but they so these fast fashion
companies they literally
do like what james charles did but even
worse they just
mass produ they ripped off i'm not so
against it because like
weren't you gonna buy a kim kardashian
versace dress you know like you might as
well get it from fashion nova it's not
like versace's hurt yeah no you're right
you're right they do sometimes rip off
like small yeah i don't know for sure
i've seen that
forever 21 does that too yeah i know
they all do it it's horrible
they haven't ripped off teddy fresh
though no not really
no beef we're friends with the show
folks oh fashion nova i don't know
i don't like them they try to [ __ ] me
you they gotta pay up they gotta wet my
beak
are you gonna bleep it no i want fashion
nova to know that they gotta email
me and pay up i like fashion over they
had discount codes they do do plus size
they do have fast fashion wait now what
the [ __ ] why are we doing an actual plug
now
i promise you i didn't get any money
what the [ __ ] was that
that was a total plug problem i'm not
even wearing fashion nova but this is
doll's kill this is misguided like
there's no fast what's your
code i want a code but they usually do
have codes if you go to their website
seventy percent off
stop this is a plug
i promise you 77 don't go to fashion
nova they're
they are criminals they're not criminals
they're criminals might be i don't know
don't have evidence of it but
you don't want to talk about any other
tick tockers so you can headline that
for your highlights channel
say what what'd you say you don't want
to talk about any tech talk stuff oh
what do you want to talk about i'm not
i'm not aware of any tech talk drama
where have you been the hype house is
getting sued noah beck said not a big
deal that they went to the bahamas like
there was a bunch of stuff oh yeah they
went to the bahamas there's
the hype house got sued for um
yeah tony lopez and little huddy and
thomas petro or whatever
so i did read about that that guy tony
lopez is such a creep
yeah like he's actually like sexting
such a weirdo so they're suing him and
then i guess all of his friends who
literally
they weren't accused of anything but
they were named in the lawsuit i guess
for
um yeah i don't really know exactly but
tony lopez like actually was like
sexting minor isn't
but whenever i see his tick tocks i go
oh this guy's such a [ __ ] weirdo
still around let me show you this let me
show you this one tick tock i saw
that was literally on my pa on my page
on your for you page on my for you page
i don't watch tony lopez
look at this
[Music]
how was that allowed on tick tock how
was that a lot on tick tock
i was like bro you better not show me
the [ __ ] tick tock again
did you put that like not interesting
how does he have a tic tac when he's
actually sexting minors like how is that
a theme yeah it seems like he
actually so yeah tony lopez disgusting
i don't know what's the deal with james
no james charles didn't go to the
bombers but like the demilio family
their parents their parents are such
idiots yeah they everyone is saying they
should
go to the airport and on airplanes and
like
right now of all time do you want to
watch noah buck's response to it yes
please
i love trisha this is why you got to
bring preparation because i'm not
totally in tune
why why you can't expect me to be
prepared okay i love talking about this
okay okay okay oh wait that's just my
tic tac okay you guys are getting a lot
of backlash for going to uh
bahamas what do you think about that how
do i pause okay
sleeveless hoodie is the worst garment
of man this guy
after watching this like might be like
the dumbest person on planet earth yeah
he does strike me
no but like really dumb like almost like
he needs to have a caregiver
to like watch out for him you know what
i mean like i'm kind of like it's like
not fair that he's on social media he's
the type of dude like in zoolander who
would be pumping gas in his car and
being like
having a water fight for sure oh my god
for sure for sure yeah
it is what it is you know like it is
what it is you already here
especially like in the business that
we're in yeah it's like
you need you need some time to kind of
disconnect a little you know
oh you [ __ ] idiot
your life as a tick tocker is the
hardest profession
yeah okay wait it gets worse yeah that's
what that was meant for it's just a
little
trip to get away like when you get away
from me you
[ __ ] idiot you took a time to jet
yeah
so it was just us okay that's not the
point
you're spreading by going from country
from la which is a high covert case to
another country that doesn't get tested
as much as a coven it's like you're
spread it doesn't matter if you're a
private jet you're still around people
in the resort your fans you're taking
pictures with fans with no masks on like
you're an idiot it's not the private jet
that is worried about getting
i can't get over the fact that he in his
profession he just needs
that's what that was like dude you're
you're not a doctor you're not a [ __ ]
you make tick tocks at home you [ __ ]
idiot
and you like live in like a 5 million
house like a pool it's like you're
probably fine
dude you are so that is like the most
deluded statement of this decade our
christmas we didn't see anyone we didn't
see my sister we didn't see my mom we
saw
nobody on christmas because of all this
like we know people personally i have
had coveted and it's like
in the hospital but listen in our
profession
we are the hardest work we are under so
much stress
yeah doctors are doing doctors and
frontline workers and nurses are having
a hard time but
i just had to take it off to the bahamas
and
by the way if a few people in the
bahamas die i mean does anyone really
care
nobody knows yeah it's so like it's just
like it's
i don't know whatever i just it gets me
like so mad because these people are so
stupid and it's like uh this is what i'm
saying these people don't deserve it
because they're so
like self-absorbent he's very young
though but whatever you gotta
you gotta own it bro don't be such an
idiot i blame the parents at that age
bad parenting i mean but they're old
enough to know it's like you know 19.
like the dixie parents
went i mean they enable it it's like oh
well these adults think it's fine so
must be i don't know
uh seeing if i had any other dramas to
talk about so do you think
donald trump should be impeached what
wow you really what about the 25th
amendment
what is that it's when they revoke they
say you can't be president any longer
because you're not
fit to serve mentally you know what i
will say was unfair to trump
like twitter like freedom of speech
yeah but so you're missing a huge piece
to the puzzle
probably because i don't know anything
about it he incited a riot
and he did oh he started the capital
riots yes
them to do it how he did so he he held a
huge rally outside
he held a huge rally one hour before
they voted to certify
uh biden and he basically riled them up
said it was stolen and then told them to
march on the capitol
and they they marched to the capitol
five people died
two officers died and they
it was insane it was crazy they were
there with zip ties they were trying to
kidnap
um like nancy pelosi they were trying to
kidnap her
and uh and then tr while it was
happening trump refused to call in the
national guard to help them
and he was like watching on the tv
loving it and refusing to send in
the national guard and the vice
president and the speaker had to
eventually
go behind his back and do it yikes it's
all on the television
it sounds like the plot to borat
remember when he tried to kidnap pamela
anderson with that bag in the book
signing
right so twitter banned trump it's not a
first amendment thing he literally is a
danger
to to himself and others why wasn't he
51 50 then
good question because that's what
happened that's what the 25th is it's a
51.50 for the president
it is really yeah i guess he is the
president
yes is he still the president he is the
president until the 20th if
do you think he'd come on the show or no
like sorry yeah you come on
because he's like he likes like
attention trump would definitely come on
frenemies
yeah he needs a platform oh he can be on
our show though
yeah cause he's posting it yeah yeah
i'll have uh i'll have ian reach out
interesting um i don't know if you have
mark meadows do you have mark meadows
email
i'm not a trump supporter all i'm saying
is like it's just twitter but i guess
did he incite it on twitter or he
incited it in real life
both he was using he was posting videos
so during the riot he was posting videos
to twitter being like
the election listen you guys have to be
peaceful
even though the election was stolen they
stole it from us this has never happened
before
uh the you know he was he was and he was
drumming them up
there's a lot i would i would they don't
ban me first like squirting on twitter
they're like that's fine
that's sexual you're not trying to kill
people you don't think i'm inciting i
feel like i inside a lot of you you're
deciding riots with
squirting people get so mad like they
don't well that's not your intention
right oh you think it was like his
intention to start a riot
maybe he was just passionate i don't
know i don't know anything about it so
like i don't support trump
but no he's [ __ ] his life is ruined
it's crazy um yeah there's a tick-tocker
who supported
who said she voted for trump and then
like everyone canceled her and then she
came back and was like oh no like i
don't care about projects and now she's
like
[ __ ] you guys like i support trump and
then they cancel her again by the way
i'm not mad at people that supported
trump there's nothing wrong with voting
for donald trump
right that i'm not mad i get that that
was half the country you don't like him
personally
i don't like him personally but like he
represents a lot of conservative ideas
that people
identify with and so they vote for him
and and even if you like him that's fine
i think that that there you have no
blame you there's nothing wrong with
the fact you voted for trump i think now
that all this has happened it's
important to just kind of
okay can i change my stance on this i
you should look into it before you
change your stance
no i was gonna say i don't like trump
anymore i don't think i don't think i
have empathy for him a little bit you
just
just watch the news for an hour i have
no more empathy for him i don't like him
actually okay thank you
we did it guys no but can i just say
getting banned on twitter is like
getting banned on instagram it really
doesn't matter they were both dying
anyways
dude twitter uh trump getting banned on
twitter is like
life ruining for him that is crazy just
go on tick tock
tick tock banned him facebook banned him
instagram banned him
twitter abandoned shopify abandoned
paypal abandoned no he's like
canceled youtube answered the president
and then what was crazy is that now the
pga tour
said that they're canceling all events
at trump golf courses
he is so fun they edited the part out
with donald trump and home alone too
over christmas did you see that on tv
yeah no really no i saw it on the
website
yeah and that were you saying well oh
maybe they were i mean i didn't i was
sitting there watching it i i haven't
seen oh it was a joke because everyone
was saying that they cut it out which
they kind of should
we don't want to incite more riots with
him and home alone too that's the last
thing america needs
we're trying to recover we cannot have
donald trump and home alone too people
i love the celebrity apprentice i just
want to be on the show so bad i've never
even watched a single episode
was it a good one really yeah oh i loved
it i loved it
it was so good um
it's my dog what is he doing he's
itching
oh my god going to town
um well i i i don't support trump
please watch the news because this is a
very important time to be alive just for
an hour
are you talking to me personally or then
yes to you probably not
okay i tried you think it's a good time
to be alive is that what you just said
no i said it's a
it's very this is what's happening now
is something that people will talk about
for the entire history of america i am
tired of living through historical
events like i
don't want to do it anymore yeah like
september 11th was traumatizing
you know and now we have a pandemic like
i don't want to live through these
historical events
well you know what gandalf said to frodo
he said let me look it up
exactly pop culture loser right here you
don't know anything about it i haven't
even seen lord of the rings and i know
the quote
what is it who are the two characters
because i can probably tell you what the
quote is
to to uh frodo
oh [ __ ] i really don't know this movie
so what the [ __ ] why are you flexing you
don't even know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about you know the movie you
don't even know
i wish it need not have happened
in my time said frodo and so do i said
gandalf
and so do all who see such times but
that is not for them to decide
all we have to decide is what we do with
the time that is given to us
do you think i'll go in the history
books i mean let's be real probably not
you don't think so i won't but we might
have a movie made after us maybe me
no you don't think they'll be moving you
have a lot of work to do if you want a
movie
that sounds like like when your
neighbor's having sex when you live in a
crappy apartment yeah
you guys having sex down there where's
the papa john sign
why do you have that over there it's a
long story can i have it no
why why do you want it it's not your
business did you steal it why do you
want it
we got it on craigslist papa john's
sucks dominoes is better
all right this show's over we're out of
juice is there any other tick tock drama
you want to talk about
oh um no i think that's it okay
so follow me on tick tock just like fish
88 fashion nova thank you
no stop fashion [ __ ] nova
such weirdos [ __ ] fashion nova
[ __ ] them what if they sponsor us if
they sponsor us then i'll be friends
with fashion nova but the way they're
trying to snake in
is some [ __ ] i don't know how i feel
about sneaking them
in i didn't get paid for it but i kind
of feel like i accomplished a goal that
i didn't think i'd be able to accomplish
but then also i'm not getting paid for
it so i kind of feel bad
you got to tell them try this be like yo
i mentioned you
you owe me you should have done them the
whole time send them my invoice
oh yeah sentiment just sent him an
invoice
okay [ __ ] fashion nova here's the
invoice
all right um anyway so next video next
week my music video will be out next
week uh sad boy 2005.
next week we'll plug it we want to do it
now next week we're going to do trivia
grilled cheese and magic underwear
mormons tell us if we can do the magic
underwear am i am i do i have to get
stuff around can we
rely on the production team we can rely
on the production but i'm not sure i
like this idea
i love this idea call it
i don't know i'm really bad the biggest
trivia show uh trisha's revenge
trisha's trivia revenge can we should we
bring some cash in like some like
i like that idea yeah just
all right thanks but you can't know you
can't know the answers i
what the [ __ ] all my jew stuff on here
my hand of god my
star of david we went to the falafel
truck and all the israelis loved me
they're like treasure
we invited them to the wedding why they
know who you are yeah they got really
excited
and then i had my israeli boyfriend to
flex with like babes to be keeper to
them
very cool all right guys see you next
week
[Music]
you